hello everyone this is Amir from audio
science review I thought I started a new
series on fundamentals of electrical
engineering not to teach you electrical
engineering for that you need to go to
school and spend quite a bit of time
learning how to design circuits but
there's a set of lingo we use in talking
about audio products in in product
reviews I do or discussion and it's
important for you to understand that and
also comes in handy as I'll explain
later if you want to change power
supplies and so forth what's involved
and I get a lot of questions about that
it's not a long presentation and my goal
again is very specific to just make sure
you're familiar with the lingo in the
context of audio
and I'm going to start with voltage and
current the two fundamental uh
components of any audio circuit so let's
get into that oops
they're uh starting with voltage uh the
symbol for this V all over the world but
for some strange reason in uh Germany
they use U over there very confusing for
us when we look at the explanation of
engineering that has you and there's the
voltage they use I think V for velocity
but the rest of the world world
correctly has standardized on V for
voltage there are two kinds of voltage
um the one is called alternating current
and we say AC the other one is direct
current which is actually called DC
um AC is what most common examples what
comes out of your wall outlet and DC is
what a battery produces as the best
example and but we can also convert AC
to DC as I'll talk about
key thing about voltage is that it pick
can be quite dangerous uh standard sort
of threshold that of when it starts to
become dangerous is 30 volts although
you know I think 40 50 volts probably
okay but we'll give you a jolt uh and it
get as it gets harder and harder you
know you can get serious shock and or
die so uh voltage is critical to
understand that concept if you're going
to get inside of a audio equipment take
a top off it's important to identify you
know whether it's a high voltage device
so it's low voltage and I'll talk about
this a little bit more later on
um the other part about voltage is that
it can cause serious damage to the
equipment
um if you feed it too high a voltage so
let's say you have it you know DAC or
something runs with nine volt power
supply external one and you replace that
with a 12 volt or 15 Volt or 20 volt it
might work it might work and run hot and
die soon or it may just damage it
immediately so it is extremely important
that if you're gonna change a power
supply or mess with something there that
you match the voltages that if the
device says I want a nine volt you know
I give it nine volt
um one of the things I do is that
whenever I have a device that becomes
obsolete or broken May throw out the
device but I always keep their power
supplies around and when I need a power
supply with the right jack I go in the
box with you know 100 different powers
replies in there looking for the right
voltage current dollar address in a
second but voltage is the first thing
you want to look at and of course if
it's an adapter you want to make sure
that connector matches
on that if you have two lower voltage
you can't damage the device but it may
not turn on
and it may uh turn on and act flaky uh
it may get stuck in an infinite Loop
where it tries to turn on and turns off
so again best is stick with whatever
voltage that you need to have for the
device to operate that the designer
assumed
nothing runs almost nothing runs in on
AC in audio devices I guess if you have
a turntable or something like that and
it's got an AC motor that may be uh you
know one of the exceptions but the
number one thing we need to do in any
audio device is take AC and convert it
to DC and that's the thing that drives
electronic circuits this is the job of a
power supply which I'm sure you're
familiar with power supply can be
internal to a device I prefer that for
most devices because then there's just
an AC cord that comes out and I don't
have to worry about a you know big wall
wart sitting outside
um in that case AC is actually going
inside the device and therefore the
inside of the device can be quite hot
and quite dangerous so that's one of
those cases where you don't want to just
open the top and start you know touching
things even if it's unplugged it can
cause serious shocks so uh be careful
about that but it can that AC can also
come in the form of just stepping it
down so this is an example of a step
down
Transformers as you probably you know
have seen these are quite heavy one over
there like this almost always their AC
although there are some that are DC
output but it will say on the back
whether the output is AC or DC and if
it's just AC like this one is it just
has a Transformer and the turns ratio
primary to secondary determines they uh
whether you can step whether stepping up
or stepping down it always steps down
for audio circuits so
um that's what these are they're
becoming much less common these days but
you know this is actually from a new
topping deck topping headphone amp that
came with this power supply
so they do exist but they're less common
um uh it can also be DC output most
common is the usb chargers for your
phones they put out you know 5 volt DC
in the form of USB plug and uh generally
though this is not used as is internally
a lot of audio devices require multiple
voltages not just one so they take
either one of these outputs and then
convert them again to whatever they need
and or they may clean up the uh uh the
output of this thing this is designed to
be pretty cheap
and you may need much higher Precision
Power Supply inside that's less noisy
and what have you
excuse me
um uh careful in swapping one for the
other so if you have uh you know uh a an
AC input device don't replace it with a
DC One
um because first of all these things are
not exact they don't put out an exact
voltage so while this says five volt
even if you got a Transformer that puts
out five volt and that's just nominal if
you actually measure with no load maybe
six or seven volts and uh the uh in
general you don't want to feed devices
designed for DC for AC input
feet at DC and vice versa so don't mix
the types I don't want to get into
complicated discussion of when it can
work it is possible for it to work but
at high level don't confuse one for the
other a lot of audio files are anxious
to quickly change their power supply for
a better one fine if it's a DC one you
have many choices but the moment it
becomes AC you cannot change this with
anything else because this is not a
complete power supply it's just a Step
Down Transformer the rest of the power
supply is internal
okay now there are two types of power
supplies I've been showing you uh the
sort of the two types uh this is half of
one there's a linear power supply and
linear ones means you have a Transformer
that steps down the voltage near what
you want and then what we have out of
this that is a sine wave that's still
you know going up and down up and down
instead of being a flat line so we run
it through a set of components called
diodes which I'll cover in a future
video and what these diets do instead of
having a sine waves goes positive
negative it'll flip the negative to the
positive so it goes positive positive
positive positives and then that's still
not DC that's still you know like
camel's hump and so we use a capacitor
which I'll talk about in another video
to get rid of those valleys in there and
we get something approximate say at DC
they are very simple trivial to design I
think I designed the first one when I
was designed built the first one when I
was seven or eight years old uh it's
just go goes back you know decades and
very very simple to build switching
power supplies are newer and much more
complicated even something as small as
this has got a lot of fancy circuits in
there and the way these things work is
that they take the high voltage AC
that's coming in right here first thing
they do is convert it to very high
voltage DC just the same process that I
just talked about but no step down and
then they'll switch the the converter
back to AC why did I do that because
60hz requires is gonna giant
transformers but if you run this thing
at 30 kilos 50 100 kilos or even you
know more than that then the
Transformers shrink and you're able to
build the power supply that puts out
good bit of power in such a small uh
size and
uh yeah so you get efficiency they get
smaller
um there may or may not be issues with
them using them in audio equipment a
smart designer can make either one of
these work and they have pros and cons
uh in there
um
I made a mention of this earlier that
your devices do have secondary and
tertiary and even more regulations
internally so don't assume just because
you can go get another you know five
volt power supply that's much bigger and
fancier and cost 500 that you're going
to get better performance internally
um most likely if the device ships with
this I measure it that way and if I show
you fantastic measurements means you
don't need to muck with this thing the
same dirty external power supply is good
enough and it's good enough because
internally they you know made sure that
cleaning the wash and wash the dishes
dishes multiple times to get them very
very clean
um
then some people say when they see a
internal power supply then they think
okay I'm gonna go clean up my AC or use
a better power cord I've covered and
reviewed tons of these products not one
makes a one iota of difference in the
output of your audio device so why
because we already go through multiple
stages of conversion and rectification
and filtering in the power supply in the
audio device so these things are almost
universally waste of money and and uh
money and equipment and space that you
that you allocate to
I always stay with the power supply that
every device comes with never ever
bother with anything different when I'm
testing a few times I've tested I've got
higher end lab power supplies and other
things I just don't find the difference
between them so what matters is the
design of your audio product and if it's
designed well it's immune to these kind
of vagaries
so that's voltage
um I'll come back to a little bit of
voltage later on but let's talk about
current current is not the same as
voltage uh even though it pairs with it
by itself is not dangerous so I could
have a thousand amps uh battery I said
300 amps in here for example and you
touch one of the terminals nothing will
happen if the voltage is low so a 12
volt battery in your car is massive if
you shorted massive amount of Sparks
come out and heat and everything but if
you just touch it nothing bad happens
whereas if you touch the these terminals
when they're plugged into the wall you
could kill yourself so very different
than voltage so too much current is not
dangerous by itself until you short
enough if you don't short it out it's
very very harmless
unlike voltage you can have too much
current and it's perfectly fine so let's
say you know you got this five volt one
amp power supply that your device came
with and you lose it or you want to
upgrade it you can get a 503 amp on 5
amp on 10 amp 100 amp it doesn't matter
the device only draws what it wants the
one amp is not jammed into its throat
indeed if it comes with a one amp power
supply it probably uses a lot less than
one amp it may have been the cheapest
one they could get was one amp you could
measure the current there's an ammeter
you can use to measure current but uh
you know just do not worry do not sort
the details of that a lot of times I get
questions on a forum people send me
messages I need a I found a 24 volt
power supply and instead of 5 amps and
seven amps and safe to use it is
absolutely safe to use if it's
compatible if the voltage is the same
and the connector is the same do not
worry about it uh basically costs you
more money for more current and more
size and potentially less efficiency but
otherwise it's fine so know that current
is drawn as needed voltage is always
used all the time at the full amplitude
Okay
um if you have too little current that
can be a problem uh like I said this may
be a one amp one and you go find a half
an amp one you plug it in
um and uh the device may do one of many
things first you may not power up at all
it may not do anything you plug it in
and it just stays dead or it may look
like it wants to power up and it shuts
down usually there's an initial surge of
current that it needs and the cohesion
current the runtime current is actually
lower than the initial search and so you
need that extra current for it to start
up if you don't have that sometimes you
get in a infinite Loop if it's a
microprocessor like if you have
Raspberry Pi single board computer if
you have too little corn it may start
and shut off and start and shut off
start and shut off
um so whenever you see that cycling that
probably means that by the way don't let
it keep cycling that is not good for it
because create surges and everything
that could damage it but typically
nothing terrible happens so if you have
a you need a three amp 9 volt power
supply and all you can find is a two amp
one it's worth a try you can plug it in
quickly and see if it Powers up and it
may run because again the device doesn't
need all that car and that's rated for
the maximum okay
um so this is a we've talked so far
about concept of bringing power into a
device but we also have devices audio
devices that generate powers of their
own and amplifiers are one of them
um
funny things about power is that the
formula for power is I times V so
voltage times current so at the same
time it appears to rely on both of those
factors at the same time in reality
that's not the case it's sort of a
parabolic kind of thing in that if the
impedance or the resistance or the load
itself is high impedance
it likes to have More Voltage before you
can get the power that you want out of
it if it's low impedance or low
resistance then it wants more current
that exact point where we go from one to
the other is design dependent and power
dependent but as a rule of thumb for
power amplifiers for Adam speaker loads
let's say or even higher if you have
those kind of speakers then the output
the voltage for the amplifier matters
more so there are amplifiers you can buy
where you have to provide the power
supply yourself and let's say you
provide a 36 volt power supply for it
but it accepts also 48. you want to get
the 48 one if your speaker impedance is
eight or more higher turns out in most
uh speakers I test are forum and lower
that means they want current that
doesn't mean that the one current and no
voltage but you know strictly speaking
you know you need to have more current
so a lot of people are confused thinking
that if they have a more higher current
amplifier is better for any load it is
not remember current is used as needed
so if you have a high impedance load it
doesn't matter if the amplifier can
drive five times as much current if the
load is not pulling that current it's
it's a material for headphones headphone
impedances can go way up to 600 ohm even
one kilo ohm generally if I were to pick
a number would be around 50 home
anything higher than 50 Beyond likely is
voltage limited so if you get for
example a phone dongle
that you get as a headphone adapter
those things are almost always voltage
limited they only put out one volt for
example they're really old crappy ones
the decent semi decent ones put out two
votes and that's good they're not very
nice ones without four volts The More
Voltage they put out the better it can
they can drive high impedance headphones
like a Sennheiser HD you know 650 that's
a 300 ohm impedance it wants voltage if
it doesn't matter if you have 10 amps
powering it it wants voltage so if you
output voltage of your dongles only one
volt good luck you're just going to get
a very faint sound and it's just not
going to get loud the bass is going to
be loud
okay so for this reason when I do my
headphone amplifier testing I show that
32 ohm and I should also show that 300
ohm so one emphasizes voltage the other
one emphasizes cart
okay
this is a very Advanced topic it's
something electrical engineers know but
you'll hear the lingo from us
occasionally I sometimes say to my
reviews the notion of what is a voltage
source an ideal voltage source is
something that puts out a voltage and no
matter how much you try to drag that
voltage down it will not come down
what that means is that if you have an
amplifier that's a that's a voltage
source
um if you keep lowering the load
impedance and make it smaller and
smaller you actually get more and more
power so when you go from 8 ohm to 4 ohm
you double the power you go to two ohms
you quadruple the power and if you go to
one ohm it goes 16 times the power and
it keeps doubling about eight times more
and it keeps doubling up forever in
reality we don't get that because
building such an amplifier that can sink
so much current is very hard to
impossible so at some point the voltage
actually starts to Sag and you don't get
that ratio of doubling I showed this
when I test headphone amplifiers in that
I start from 300 ohm load 600 ohm load
go all the way down 12 ohms so very wide
range and typically you see in here at
the end uh what happens with these top
two loads usually from 600 to 300 uh
headphone amplifiers don't care
basically stay a perfect voltage source
some of them would say perfect voltage
source even down to 50 ohm but usually
around that point the voltage starts to
drop it sags so you don't get a doubling
of power you start to lose that doubling
with every bit in there so
the most perfect headphone amplifier
would be the one again that the voltage
never changes and if it did that going
from 600 to 12 ohms you get 50 times
more power
which is unreasonable to expect but you
know just remember that's what this
means if somebody says well this thing's
acting like an ideal voltage source
means that no matter how much you try to
draw from it it stays put and it doesn't
drop its voltage in audio the
transmission mechanism from one
component to the other is through a
voltage source so your Source let's say
it's a DAC driving an amplifier it puts
out let's say four volts and it will
hold that four volts and that is what
transfers a signal into the other one
the current is negligible in that case
anyway so and same with amplifier to the
speaker it wants to be a voltage source
if it can okay there is such a thing as
a current Source it doesn't have this
kind of user visible feature it's used
in designing electronic circuits for
biasing purposes and so forth where
you'll create it what's called a current
source which is opposite of voltage so
it always maintains the same current but
it's not something you're going to see
me use or talk about
um you know maybe when Engineers talk
about the the
circuit design you'll hear about that
but otherwise it's not something that
you're going to see
so this is it I wanted to keep this
presentation short and sweet
where just get you introduced to these
things and then in the future videos I
plan to do videos on what is a capacitor
and what is the resistor and transform
and diets and so forth not sure how far
I'll go down that path but again my goal
is that you'll have an understanding and
a sort of a reference for these Concepts
otherwise you won't be able to fully
follow what the uh you know the reviews
are saying or what the technical people
are arguing with each other
okay put in a comment how you like this
whether you'd like to see more of these
things or not uh otherwise I'll just go
back to do more reviews okay see you in
a future video bye